everybody what's going on bleh here and
welcome to today's Monday melee yes
dreamily excited because this week we
have the creator of Mortal Kombat in the
creative director of NetherRealm Studios
Edie Boone is here give him a hand
and Tyler what's your last name time
lands down Tyler yeah Wow screwed out of
Game of Thrones Tyler Lansdowne is here
as well and we're gonna be playing
Mortal Kombat X or Mortal Kombat 10
comes out tomorrow ps4 Xbox one and
there's also PC also and PC because we
know how much you guys love PC as well
people just scream why aren't you
playing PC games we're going to
eventually I promise you but there's
also a great mobile game yeah that
people are loving how can people get
that in the old Apple Store in the old
Google Play Store all those things and
if you have a flip phone I can't help
you try dialing star something maybe you
can get that Google Play in a few days
but Apple Store is right now free play
fantastic and all this all this great
stuff comes out tonight at midnight so
for for you fans of Mortal Kombat uh and
so yeah we're gonna play I'm very
excited because we did a clueless gamer
in the Super Bowl
Tyler was there and you were there in
spirit yeah and and it was great
Marshawn Lynch and Gronk played Conan at
Mortal Kombat but you didn't get to see
the whole game at that point because it
was still kind of in development so I'm
super excited this is the full game so
there's gonna be great I can't wait to
get murdered by Tyler who plays this
professionally I wouldn't go that far
that's right professional that's right
exactly so I so explain the thing they
or a couple things that you're most
excited about about the new Mortal
Kombat right off the top of my head the
the big new feature with the game is
every every character in the game
there's three versions ya know when they
play differently they have different you
know strategies different you know it
moves amongst them so it really appeared
really adds to the depth and matchups of
the key so right here these variations
exactly and so you can so and a lot of
them generally are I mean they're
obviously different for every single
player they're unique to the player and
some of them are a little more defensive
a little more error based or exactly
some of them are more defensive some
offensive some are kind of like you know
grapplers all every different up things
so if you're really good at the
character but it matches a bad with
another character yes you find another
variation there in general people are
very in amazingly loyal to their
characters they'll play oh my god they
don't think it's the best one in the
game just because they love the
character that's hilarious anything and
it's so there is hope if you keep
getting your butt beat there still is
hope with the you could try a new
variation yeah and then go back at all
right well let's get into it let's blow
it a lot I'm gonna go with my new main
character sorry we should have wait hold
on let me you know what I gotta go new
user
there we go please guests do it nope
perfect no I'm in uhm
all right great should we switch
controllers you want to well big time
just saying what should match up how it
is do you want to says the guy I mean
you know might be a disadvantage for you
I need all the help I can get you know
huh thank you I love it all right
see you're I think I'm gonna go oh man
you're going K know I look so badass by
the way I love how long did it take to
kind of design the newbie all these new
characters and that kind of a thing the
whole project is about two years you
know and we were kind of messing around
with different different things but one
sweet what we kind of realized how cool
the variation system was gonna be yeah
that really just you know set things off
you know it was it was a lot of work a
lot of these characters you know it's a
huge balancing issue you know making
sure that every character can come and
face off with the other ones but the
yeah two years from beginning to end was
about the length of project that's
awesome Oh somebody's saying cage versus
Kano battle Lord 17 all right I'm gonna
go cage oh how cool is this dude he's
grown up a little bit got a great North
Face Jack and I 25 years older than he
was before
oh that's so cool but he's got a little
greatness hair that act a little bit
more
but he's still really cocky he's still a
douche yeah let's hear what am i
different variations stunts new stunt
double stump doubles awesome he sends
out these clones of himself mr. kuffs
that's great I'm gonna fisticuffs let's
you know I like to get in getting some
knuckle some yeah exactly do you have it
do you have a favorite I know it's kind
of choosing between your children yeah
but most parents do that and you know it
scars their children for life so it
scorpions been my favorite oh one of the
you know one of the characters from the
original cast in 1992 yeah seven
characters now we've got you know 25
plus characters when scorpions always
been amazing I mean I went through a
whole period in my life where I just
said get over here to everybody yeah
yeah I think everybody went through that
that's actually my voice yelling get
over here no is that true yeah
oh my hair it quickly tone of people
here you guys can't see in the room and
everyone just went like they were
horrified I think most of most of the
people might have wedded here so that's
a little a little abrasive awesome Tony
said boon hype exactly food Hoyt
hashtag boon hype all right let's do it
pick a pick a level here we haven't seen
let's do I really love the look who just
freaked out that you say I really love
this one here this guy temple with all
the rain let's do a fax let's do it so
go ahead you can flip down there to a
little random between us if you disagree
yeah it flips the coin and they'll talk
to each other as like every different
conversation there yeah that's great a
new little mini scene
oh nice you can actually pick up one of
those those praying monks over there and
throw them oh yeah I missed it
you're gonna paint dearly for it wait so
tell us a little bit about the mobile
games
oh the mobile game is it's a crazy
phenomenon right now that's a
free-to-play game and it's actually
linked with the console version Wow
something that's really cool so you if
you get the mobile game you you get some
accomplishments on that one you can
actually unlock skins that's in the
console games inside Johnny cages and
gets trapped in a glass
that's his glut the glass boxes yeah
thing you can't come back in it's
awesome JAXA these are exclusive so
that's crazy
millions of people are downloading it
every day it's ridiculous it's kind of
like our we had an injustice oh yeah so
we're really excited about that how the
two games are getting across
so wait the only way like that I can get
like the ninja the ninja is by is by get
download that's for you wow that's
fantastic
good lord the I must say one of the
things I love and sitting with injustice
too is if you like picking up a monk and
throw him like the interaction with the
environment yeah if you go go all the
way to the left let me go to the left
before you just murder me
all right through the fire over there
that's hot throw that monk over there
you can run up and there's also a
- yeah right side there's two different
things on the right side so you can get
used to escape or you can use it to
attack bonk now no.5 the game comes out
for ps4 PC and Xbox one tonight at
midnight and the the mobile game is
already available on the Apple Store and
probably by the end of the week we'll be
in Google Play you know Google those
guys
alright now this game is obviously
insanely brutal which is fantastic and
there are any moves that didn't kind of
make it in that you wanted to see me
yeah yeah you cannot but you can use
PlayStation 3 sticks on the PlayStation
4 there we go fantastic are you mean
like arcade sticks is that we got yeah
we got some cool and justice ones that
are another new fighter uh be aware
there some moves that kind of didn't
make it end yeah every every once in
while somebody will suggest something
and everybody kind of cringe
I think if fatality should be reading
quietly to yourself in a room so yeah
not a good fatality I love it but yeah
as you notice you know there's the three
variations of every character I'm yeah
I'm really looking forward to as
somebody who completely mastered the
character we just had a tournament
before oh that's good a guy was playing
I was on Saturday and and the guy was
playing scorpion he wasn't doing that
good so he switched up to the
he went from Hellfire to the u of the
ninja to the Hellfire yeah just said he
changed the way exactly and anyone any
any want his is round but that kind of
stuff is like you know we're really
excited about how so nice it's scorpion
vs Sub Zero will do scorpion for subs
your next classic matchup we'll do that
next week why are you here where am I
would you choose there's a lot of
interactable stuff down here left Oh
Alec had asked how much have you played
your own game how much have you played
the Mortal Kombat franchise um you know
and usually while we're making the game
I get to you know I'll play it as we're
like putting in new characters and
whatnot but towards the towards the end
like like the the game just consumes all
my like you know Tyler can easily tell
like you kick anybody's ass you know
works going whole bunch which is you
know this helps us get to know the game
sure yeah
and also pretty I mean in there is a
certain amount that you have to play for
quality testing and all these other and
truthfully like we have a lot of fun
well I really love playing the games I'm
sure yeah which is a good feeling
so and and and so like what is like can
you take us through and I know it's a
giant process but like my metal aren't
your metal arms are gonna get really
cold in this weather it's anything like
and though I was talking that the result
every character has something to say
that's so great the game so it's so
whenever you're playing the game you
always hear something are you still
score you know you're not scoring oh
yeah oh you're so serving
yes over over oh my god that's awesome
I'm actually I'm told the beginners
records the longest video game boys oh
my god that's it
give me a Oh see I should have
introduced use world record holder also
yeah yeah you know who's number two the
guy oh really
yeah that's you beat ya head beat Mario
I'm top nice I love it and also you know
Scorpio would beat Mario in a fight
although not if there are pipes involved
I feel like Mario is the up and if
stream told me to stop taking it easy
okay yeah I don't want to though oh yeah
it's a yeah we were gonna go through
kind of how the game is VI how does
that's got to be one of the first things
you kind of decide right yeah it's one
of the toughest things that we do you
know mole combat has about 70 or so and
I'm characters I've introduced over the
years and you know we can't make a game
with 70 years ago inevitably somebody's
left out and people character and so but
we also have DLC characters where what
we have an additional characters
we have predator from the movies is
gonna be a Jason from Friday the 13th
oh my god that's awesome so you can I
can play predator versus Jason exactly
holy Moses and how did that how did that
even come about like you know we did a
Freddy Krueger from Alaska okay Freddy
Krueger and he was you know everybody
loved him so we knew we're gonna have
more guest characters yeah inspired Wow
that's and that is one of the grossest
things I've ever seen in my life yeah
you basically made my skull into blood
soup I do look to you like and we kind
of talked about this for the zero thing
but it just keeps going we could just
watch the exactly I love it just keeps
bubbling forever so you can go and you
know make a quiche and come back and
you're the blood will still be bubbling
in this there's there's a there's a
fatality a Cassie cage Johnny's daughter
yeah there's like a like a social media
thing comes up you see the pixie
comments coming for like minutes we've
talked about like a lot of the stuff we
found in our expansive Crypt oh yeah so
a lot of fatalities you have to look
around and find them oh that's good one
to start yeah you gotta find the rest
along with brutalities yeah there's a
ton to unlock it oh man I think that's
great does the whole section called the
Crypt we go driving around and see the
reason I just logged in and saw this
kind of messed-up for people tuning in
right now they're like what is going on
I love it I love it that's fantastic yes
so so kind of the first thing you kind
of decide what characters and that's got
to be two people get into fights upon
people get an argument and and we get I
get a lot of people let's do subzero
versus
I'm sorry people get in arguments yeah
people get in arguments and you know and
fans are just as passionate probably
more so than we are as far as who did
but you know we try to tell a story you
know we have this really long expensive
story mode that's in the game which is
which is a like like watching a movie
that you're participating in and we have
so some of the characters that we want
to feature in the story we're never
gonna have a game you know without
scorpion and so right right right
exactly and Goro is this big character
that if you pre-ordered the game you get
him for free for arms Oh amazing I love
girl is in the penises life it one of my
favorite players two characters duplex
and I love big dudes who just throw
people around oh my god that's what he
does and that's like my style of
unbelievable a lot of fun great work
Ravin are there any stories behind
characters about how kind of the
characters were inspired
yes 20 um there was a character second
what's the what's the bug exactly well
it was it was basically any time that
something called a permit and so for the
next game we we made a character called
her man that's a man and he's been
around for you know 15 16 years and he
started out as a rumor and there's a
know people want him so much that's
great I'm happy about that cuz Merrimack
is my favorite character he is the
dumbest name wrote this this lore about
them is that all these souls inside
there we go a nice that's great I love I
love to they're about to fight the hey
aromatic oh don't call me by my full
name only my mother calls me aromatic oh
we should debbie hilarious yeah I love
the interactions that can get you around
the map really quickly yeah oh yeah get
you out of troubles yes just like a
corner to you go the corners
which now which variation did you choose
this is a jitsu which gives him the
swords give him a little more range
attack me also has some cool like combos
embedded within where he has more sword
attacks yeah the game is like a great
combination of in a really deep gameplay
but you know these crazy events that
yeah everybody loves to eat and I love I
love to about this one is yeah that you
have instead of just the fatalities you
have these these things the middle which
are great he's little you're saying
because and then it's like you don't
have to wait it's kind of like giving
people like like more great like
everybody has more fatalities it's
almost like a little mini victory and
they have these things mortalities and I
do love to like how they just get right
back up yeah I'm fine yeah my neck
broken it's fun I used to worry about
you know these x-rays you know you see
some of these neck is it blue they're
broken they get up and start people
suspend belief it's amazing
I know it's great well you know they're
there the grain you would expect you
know to be fair they showed up right
before we started shooting so I didn't
get any time I haven't played this in
months mutts seen I'm starting to get
crazy oh there we go oh wait what am i
doing what am i doing Fox put post push
what please bossing you look laughs good
lord
easy oh he does he does he does all
right hit your trigger yeah when you get
out of here okay go right next to the
guy okay hit your trigger and square
which trigger square I think we'll go to
moves let's make sure he's gonna work my
waiter there is yeah art yeah are - yes
square right next to him okay there you
go yes that's something else you can
find in the crypt is easy fatality nice
absolutely hey I know you lost don't go
to pieces
come on I love it
all right let's see you should we play
next door oh oh yeah yeah you play first
I'll play someone who I haven't seen you
who should we tell us who should we play
an expert now firm tours to people which
is kind of cool
you kind of got the old like a little
Mad Max Master Blaster stuff and her
tours my favorite new care thing it's
like we always want to introduce
something new and so this game is a
whole bunch of characters they're kind
of like next-generation characters yeah
some of them are the descendants of the
existing world oh that's cool like it
wait like what do you mean like crazy
cages Johnny Cage and Sonja's daughter
comes in is Kung Lao
younger cousin ders Oh awesome takeda is
is really this scorpion it's it's it's
really a cool it's a family it's a
family that's great the family reunion
for this game would be insane
Jackie is Jax's daughter too that's
awesome I love don't listen to kind of
reminiscent of her dad but they're not
actually like attached yeah yeah I've
done them and whatnot they stop it dad
I'm just gonna be gone let's leave me
alone so I actually play the fair tour
that cuz with his variations are pretty
cool he's got one that you know uses
fair a whole bunch yeah I used the one
where she just kind of stands on the
sidelines and cheers for me so I love it
I love it alright let's do it you pick
you pick the place did you pick done yet
let's see someplace new we haven't seen
the destroyed cities cool they're all
cool let's do this red city it's great
yeah I love it again thank you guys for
joining us we're here with Ed Boon and
Tyler from NetherRealm and Edie we're
just learning is the voice of scorpion
which is insane also the creator of
Mortal Kombat and as well as creative
director and another home studios and
get Mortal Kombat 10 it is out tonight
ps4 Xbox one and PC as well as download
that sweet mobile game because you can
get extra awesome stuff for the game in
the mobile game
whoo I just think this guy was fairer
tor Fair is the big guy right toward
towards a big you just get the feeling
tor just smells you know like you can't
you can't tell me tours like wow oh my
god this happened to me on a date once
it's terrible oh I love it wrecked
everyone said yeah tell us what what
characters you guys want to see us play
or slash me get murdered by Tyler from
yeah I don't know all the variations hit
with 25 characters and reburied now
Eddie back of the day when you were
first when you first kind of you know
came up with Mortal Kombat you you were
figuring the whole thing out what were
some lick your inspirations because
Mortal Kombat is set for me a
groundbreaking series and really like I
remember playing it and just being
absolutely blown away yeah everything
with everything inspired us was was
movies I mean people get first one
oh my god that's one way to get rid of a
stomachache just have somebody posture
your body if you look over the first
Mortal Kombat characters they're all
inspired by you know movies you know we
originally wanted to be a junk want that
damn game oh and you know we couldn't
make that happen so we made up our own
that's a cage John come and Emmas it
might have actually been in the game at
one point that's crazy
Wow and I don't know if you saw the
movie Big Trouble in Little China oh my
god Jack I love it and that's Raiden
Jason oh my god great Lu Kang is Bruce
Lee yeah yeah it was a little bit of um
of terminator you know what that scene
where is head so we're all kind of you
know children of movies you know Enter
the Dragon all those kind of market
that's awesome Lord where the girl come
from a nightmare somebody's that's crazy
oh my god I love that Wow yeah that is
now that you're saying it it does kind
of make sense yeah yeah yeah that's
fantastic it's a lot of that stuff that
we had you know and in the first game
the big fatality that freaked everybody
out was Sub Zero grabbing the opponent
and pulling their spine down yeah full
circle now because we have predator
that's gonna be awesome I love it
and we'll predator have some kind of
crazy fatality where he's like polishes
a skull or some kind of yeah oh my god
yeah that's fantastic yeah it is really
exciting now that you guys are gonna
kind of incorporate some movie
characters as well because
yeah now it's like you're it's almost
like cross-media
yeah we've been a number of guest
characters over the years with Kratos in
the Asian version I love from God of War
right exactly it's always I don't know
to me there's always something really
cool to see great name of your opponent
is written on the bullet it's like JFK
magic bullet no magic bullet there we go
that's hilarious
what's going on what is what is
happening in the back there I feel like
this is gonna give us some kind of crazy
it that's a big story it's like the the
ginseng chamber it's the Wi-Fi is
amazing in this room for all the evil oh
this is oh wow this is it's like we're
basically in the island and lost
he's like the smoke monster is gonna be
around here somewhere spoiler alert by
the way people haven't seen the last few
the island is yep have some pudding I'm
assuming that's clear that it just fall
it falls an evil put anything in a pot
to put him oh so oh my god you were like
enough of that Jesus
that's we have some more questions from
the old chateroo
yeah you've clay you just clay clay
statue we just like what about if we do
this every day right coming up with
really disco I feel like I would be able
to come up with some story although
they'd need more like more humiliating
emotionally you know like like she never
texts you back yeah yeah or somebody saw
like your OkCupid profile but then
didn't email here's like you set it up
right it's like fatality is 20 minutes
long as you go through whole
relationship and she breaks your heart
it's like terrible no so what's this
work that way yeah this is actually one
of the cool new features at the end
everybody who plays Mortal Kombat is
gonna be told join a faction oh cool so
so everybody online is all kind of
contributing to a weekly game that hello
everybody's participating in everything
you do in the game is contributing
points to your faction and at the end of
the week the winning faction gets
rewards well that's awesome this happens
every week so you can join you know show
your allegiance to black dragon to
special forces White Lotus holy and it's
it's really a great way for everybody to
participate in the same kind of mitigate
that's amazing we talked about like you
know ways to kill brutalities and what
yeah it when you join a faction you also
get these faction kills you'll get more
of as you level up a faction of its own
type of fatalities that you can do
that's things is there's a number of
those so so I personally am always black
dragon okay
it'll also change the background screen
when you play the game oh this is the
black dragon together like a special
forces guy tied up or yeah it looks like
not to me but to get some reservoir
dogged yeah basically so I thought if we
tried that another cuz it sort of couch
combat thing we like these testers which
is it really evens the playing field
because it just gives you these crazy
modifiers then just randomly gives you
it could give me one hit of health oh I
love it good make you regain health oh
that's awesome stuff involving power-ups
falling yes sky really that's one thing
I love I have to say like I love about
like Super Smash Brothers is that exact
thing so I love you guys incorporated
that because it is it is like we're
playing now I mean it's hard if
someone's really good to try I mean to
just get I'm just gonna get beat every
single time but would test your luck
maybe oh maybe I won't you there's a
higher chance Lansdowne if that is your
real name all true all true I know yeah
it's kids hiding from somebody yeah it's
actually this is like the greatest party
game experience sign up with your
buddies you know hanging around self
visits and also you I've gone on a rant
before I'm the streaming button I do not
like the fact that games these days seem
to be which one should I do here oh
really I'm gonna do wait I'm gonna do
where's reptile do you do it concern he
also said they want to see this guy
needs to moisturize look at that skin
that's terrible dude katana that's what
kind of eczema alright reptile it is but
I was single if there's like games seem
to be moving away from especially
multiplayer games moving away from this
kind of experience which I really love
yeah you know and so it's kind of cool
you guys are kind of crack the code to
do both play people you know online with
you know but the factions and stuff but
then also playing this because yeah
Mortal Kombat's always you know a big
part Mortal Kombat's always been you
know coop of friends all gotten around
just playing yes you could win the
longest yes you know I kind of and so we
put like you know great little kind of
party moments and whatnot because these
can get ridiculous awesome awesome let's
do it I can't wait there's one that I
hope pops up called eyes what are the
hand of God fist of God it's it's this
little yellow icon falls down if you get
it you have like two seconds guys want
him to blow the person Wow all right so
wait so explain what's gonna go on
well yeah it's gonna go through all the
modifiers that you're gonna be playing
with so you got to kind of have a chance
to mentally prepare for the inside oh my
god perfect hey Cimino this is awesome
I'm gonna lose health as we go we're
both stronger awesome more super grab
that and whoever's up on top when it
goes up this is awesome I'm constantly
losing health just randomly yeah oh
whoever said reptile in the chat room
thank you by the way that was crazy
so if I'm hot I'm hot I was getting kind
of Hardy losing health I'm losing double
healthy okay
finally I have a chance against land
like professor lands down over here oh
thank you well the Hat it's the Hat I
see my opponents weakness in real life
also when I go for it Danny so that can
really turn the tables that's great oh
man this is awesome let's do it again
okay that room improve and how many
different kind of power of stuff are
they all so you could obviously we
should you knew you can also be highly
enjoyed the game time yeah you can do
saying it oh wow that's great
oh it's that easy stuff you like that
could be a game we play every yeah yeah
that's fantastic Wow my favorite Lord
boon yeah exactly
all hail Lord doom here we go rain of
ice in a new block you can freeze me
though I see oh I see so p1 so if that's
just me I'm just a wise they're gonna go
out periodically - oh my god you're just
gonna see our hands I reflect shoot
things at me I condemn
love this we've both touched hot stoves
recently oh my god oh this is great oh
this is brilliant I love you can just
see my help going down as it goes dark
oh thanks yeah agreed
well it kind of is this squirt I mean
every time you're playing squirt you're
basically playing good we look at that
slick see we had a kitten oh yeah we had
a care what is it oh yes what now what
are some other things that people might
not know about the history of these
characters um a lot of the murmured
weird um inside jokes on it from our
part you know coming up with like a fur
Mac thing everybody spelled backwards
some of the rest how was a hidden
character in the first game Oh big sis
always were cinematic doesn't it flick
it yeah so over the years we've had a
lot of like just inside jokes
add to the mystery I love that that's so
cool
that really it's amazing to like it has
like how long one was was it 92 93 92 92
92 yeah so I mean we're talking about
now you know like like over a decade
action pretty you got set such a large
catalog and it's been a long time since
hey let's have a Jean Claude Van Damme
in a game okay
yeah that's incredible with what's
really cool too is Carl Weathers movie
yes we're gonna have a version of him
playing as Jack's oh my god oh that was
a call for that's uncalled for
yeah in the dark by the way don't even
give me the respect of hitting me in the
head in the light if there's like
welcome to my world
Tyler it's almost brand Oh give me my
world so much fun my guys at home like
when high schooler won't play good yes
these are these are the available
characters not the DLCs these right
these are all in retail yeah the DLC
characters are just characters called
tremor which is a more comic character
but very rare one other one called Tania
and the predator and Jason awesome
becoming you know certain in a few weeks
and spaced out about four weeks apart so
we're gonna the gains gonna be we're
gonna be supporting it all through the
summer mortal kombat summer carnage
hashtag summer carnage I love it I just
need to hook up my TV by the pool so
that I can just technically be outside
fantastic and also yeah for you guys it
this comes out tomorrow tonight at
midnight and go get the mole again
should be too new yeah and go get the
mobile game as well I say we do
something crazy and we do way crazier
than okay a nice ring I'd honestly not
done is that was pretty crazy I think we
should do seven model fighters exactly
go all the way to the top of modifiers
okay max modify if nothing will make
sense to you let's do it wait who should
I play who should I play Beth what is
the Chapman saying what do they want to
see I love it Oh Raiden okay great we
haven't done rates awesome Takeda slim
where's my boy rain here I had some luck
with Raiden but not with the ball
lightning one but I think it's this one
here we go seven let's do it crazy I've
had about a gallon of coffee so this is
gonna be efficiently what's going in my
brain right now
Raiden we do a lot of five seven where
it's them yeah just put your controller
oh my god
what are some other and what are some
other games out there that are out now
or have been out the past few years they
excite you that you really think oh this
is so cool like there's games for me
like cuz I love Christmas like Katamari
Damacy was such a fun games like oh I've
never seen anything like this book yeah
you know this is gonna sound like a
shameless plug but I'm really looking
forward to Arkham Knight Oh
Arkham Knight and not to see those
floods gonna be spectacular
see the game it's gonna be I'm very
excited and our health reduce our
kinetics that's fun that that game has
my favorite like fighting like me I love
X infection better but yeah there's
nothing better than jumping into like a
group of 25 guys in June yeah yeah hello
kicking the crap out of all of them it's
like oh yeah and that's also - I'm
really one thing I really love about
that game is this story oh yeah I said
it's like the conclusion yeah and it is
cool like I do really feel like I mean
look at what we're watching right now
like video games are amazingly cinematic
yeah it really does feel like they are
where they were where films were like in
the 30 yeah yeah stuff like worse we're
seeing in the game now was kind of like
our manifold
but yeah we're playing a cutscene
especially and also like it's it's so
cool to see you know like how like Carl
Weathers like all these people flocking
to Hollywood talent flocking to games
because you know how much more powerful
is telling a story if you're the person
in it yeah you know and these games yeah
like Arkham Knight I'm looking forward
to seeing what's gonna happen you know
like just like an event yeah you see
Kevin Spacey and ya know absolutely so
it's clearly there's overlap that's
happening in absolutely yeah and even
like you know Liam Neeson was like a
voice in fallout 3 which was how long
ago and so Gary Oldman did like oh yeah
mazing okay yeah I say we do who else
should we play I I kind of want to do a
rematch new modifying yeah there's a lot
of ours that it was funny cuz armor was
they were just going ding-ding-ding yeah
yeah yeah it's like we won the nickel
slots or something in Vegas like also a
sidebar I don't know when the last time
you guys were in Vegas but I went for
the first time in a long time no more
things then you just get a ticket you
don't get like a bunch of quarters
anymore that was recently there it's
awful I wouldn't I mix it makes the
noise yeah it still goes ding anything
so it's all the annoying stuff you don't
get like the joy of carrying around
5,000 quarters so we both start really
slow and the more you attack the faster
your character moves oh my god so
oh you wonder some of the modify I have
vampire touch you have you terrible
you've put on Axe body spray right
perfect so now I'm moving a little fast
yeah I've got terrible dandruff lighten
it yeah oh you see you're speeding up
this is crazy
you're already super fast
somebody just said Jason we don't have
the Jason DLC in this but there it is
Jason 13 and I'm assuming he's gonna
have these guys aren't doing their jobs
and you smell good you were just kidding
you go faster than your character or
when he hits it the more he hits you
after he goes I'm actually having
trouble doing something Oh
too fast I can't even hear the ones fast
enough Jim you're kicking your ass so
badly
oh my god and you knocked my hat off
jerk I don't care about you beating me
but just keep the fashion attacks you
know I put this outfit together it means
something to me it means something all
right let's do I need a new character I
can't I can't do this I can't I can't
see red just get beat like this I love
him too much oh girl please people are
saying girl these we don't we don't have
yet they're never locked on this builds
I haven't unlocked however I'm gonna do
someone equally horrifying cat Sonya
Blade Oh where's Cassie Cassie cuz she's
got a horrifying booth at least in dudes
or
I logged in oh yeah oh yeah so for sure
well let's keep it let's give it a five
okay five seven was kid with chaos in a
fun way and so you can play with this
game oh so you can play people over a
network that's fantastic yeah now I can
play in a lot of different ways to you
know you can get a group of people in a
room called king of the hill where one
guy you know everybody's trying to
defeat the oh my god I know you can do
you can do team battles where like five
people can play another five oh my god
that stop it sides you can get five your
friends and that's awesome and we
actually have developer icon for the
studio yeah so about furs we'll be doing
that if you beat us you get something
special too whoa there we go so people
can done for you there you think oh
please gun for Tyler avenge my death
avenge my death oh my god this is crazy
hyper combat and killer jumps by the way
this is what's going out of my brain at
all times
oh but it's kind of slow people want you
to play I do you feel like playing not
gonna play cuz he squeezed two real-life
scorpion guys breaker
I love hyper combo other one is there's
one that's you can with gravity kind of
disappears so you can bounce people over
I love it that's awesome okay we're just
chanting your name in it's awesome then
backwards it's new but forwards its
expert there we go all right we should I
proven we seen yet we've known I did
Jack haven't done Sonya haven't done so
yeah I'll play a special part so timing
take me through these variations your
Special Forces oh this is the one with
the drone right yeah that's fun covert
ops that's a military stance and she
also has different Perry's another was a
grenade with a stun grenade and a frag
grenade
I'm gonna go drone like a drone and then
kimchi's got one where is he can't use
his sword sento anymore uses of D has
been possessed by a demon whoa nasty
sort of you know uses these those sort
of you can see a little specular and
then can just use more of like a
telekinesis version of that which is
what I like smoke smoke smoke is smoke
in this no smoke no the casualty I like
it there's a smoke assist I believe yeah
there's a character Jade who died and
katana has a variation called mournful
and is kind of like James moves so she
kind of lives in spirit there we go she
has her staff and her clave that's
really cool that's awesome you guys he
did it
what's one thing like putting together
this game date that you learned like
what was one thing you kind of didn't
expect and like in the whole mortal come
K X process um well I guess we're gonna
start the learning processes tonight
they're been there whenever we had a
really great tournament that beta late
yesterday and even then yeah I'm seeing
people do stuff with the game that we
didn't anticipate so the whole like what
do you mean there's a fighting or the
Homburg that they come up with yeah
these people are like just amazing
Lexa's and strategies that they use with
the pyramid you know the theory that we
had making this game was if three
versions of every character is really
going to add the depth and they
demonstrated it was great how someone
who really loves scorpion changed the
variation isn't better with the matchup
that you know it's really what fighting
games are all about this is with other
characters and discovery exactly exactly
yeah so you see and you know with
commentators and all the strategies and
so we really build there's so much as we
learned in the next oh for sure
that is it's fun it must be I mean it's
obviously exhausting the run-up to
release but it's got to be fun when it's
out in the wild - it's it's
nerve-racking on it it's exciting it's a
lot of sleepless night yeah I can't why
I just can't wait to get online a play
yeah seriously oh god oh our buttons are
all messed up right now because of
that's one of the things ah your buttons
which I know I did guessing also
throughout the match that's changing
but either scrambled in the beginning we
had constantly scrambled but I certainly
haven't learned it off now so good lord
I love it I love it
what's that oh it's good all right cool
wait what does that say Pass me the
phone this is our awesome this is how we
communicate via phone via phone ok cool
give a few more minutes is that Alright
cool awesome alright let's play let's
try let's try a new new fighters love
yeah what time is it alright yeah one of
my guys guys if you have more questions
for ED he's got to take off soon so hit
him that you're talking to the creator
of Mortal Kombat slash creative director
another room Hey here he is
yeah come on sit down here mr. O Brien
creator of Mortal Kombat congratulations
also the voice of scorpion can you do it
again Chris over here scorpion that's my
dad in 1972 channel Tim we're playing
world combat actually played with
Marshawn yes yeah rock as well we had a
good time Tyler's here do you wanna do
you guys want to play yeah do you want
to play ed I'm very good at this game
what do I do
alright so so pick a girl we're doing
pick a guy so yeah just you're the red
square you're the guy I'm the red so
once you guys switch alright alright I'm
gonna be who's this guy who's next - how
come I can't get no it's this one it's
this quiet C for people who don't
realize we don't know about him as a
scorpion shut up alright so how do I -
right yeah ex ex don't yell I'm gonna be
that guy cuz I like his hat
look at hat that's incredible you know
what that guy's values sun protection
look at him he said a great martial
artist but he also knows to keep the Sun
off the face sugar I'm I am Kung Lao
that's right
I am scorpion okay all right so Tyler
explained we're gonna play this game
with modifiers there's gonna be things
dropping from this I'll tell you what's
gonna happen
it makes the game it just flips it on
its head so okay it's about time we
flipped it on its head we're tired of
the game being on its feet it's gonna be
ridiculousness okay we're gonna be
playing you worked in this cutting-edge
technology yes but you wear the hat of a
1930s news boy I have here we go let's
go let's do this yes there we go we'll
have after that plane so yes you're
stronger poem yes ship damages that are
we're blocking you guys are gonna get
dizzy and fate tiles will pop up
randomly wait why do we get dizzy for no
reason just to modify as I ran if the
page should go faster and player 2 is
poison oh I've been poisoned you can put
yes alright there we go oh oh my god
that was so quick yeah the finish um
we'll just randomly pop up throughout
the best oh why am i sickly you know why
the plane what do you throw at me we're
playing in the destroyed City this is
like the world did it really well I mean
wait oh nice what you've got like a
hipster keychain hidden with the hat
alright hit it with the hat I don't know
is the Hat I'm not sure which boy know
I'm dizzy again yeah
Tyler missing he's had some bad Thai
food down for crying oh my goodness down
what down for tiger it's our sis don't
worry about it you make that point
crying I can't do it down for triangle
yes hit him with the hat and hit him
with that
oh no gonna make it happen
it beats you wait what it's on the first
match but I understand why am I sick
it's one of the random modifiers in this
in this it's like epstein-barr I mean
what do we get like sort of just sick
for no reason that's ridiculous
what kind of modifier is that triggers
yes no now I'm sick again
you don't it's seasonal you think it's I
think it's call it what you won even
though I sawed your head in and then we
saw your heart yeah that's incredible
do I do it one more and then we call it
yeah yeah one more all right Rowlett how
about you guys go against these all
right all right we'll play well play
we'll play very good select a new
fighter we'll go down here hit this
alright here we go
okay oh my god wow that was all right
look I'm gonna keep my guy oh you want
all right you want to stay you want to
stay the guy with the hat yeah I want to
become loud cuz I don't want to
distribute it against him just because
what who shows the nature of his illness
what are his symptoms I'm gonna be how
about I be who should I be would you we
don't have a lot of time okay okay fine
I'll be there
I've got to go to rehearsal all right
yes yes flat last match all right 5
modifiers will play a random place you
want this just moving on with this stick
and hit this step you can also hit these
yeah I know I know yeah
and that I don't really know the moves I
can't really help you
I don't really Tyler's the guy with the
with who knows all the moves I don't
know anything here we go
here we got a child all hail reptile all
right so this is what's gonna tell us
what's going on so neither you can each
other yeah join disabled triple chip
when you're blocking you'll take more
damage okay poison rockets be getting
you why we're all just a big job rockets
which again oh yeah so hit going here
hit this hit this try go-cart going
forward none of the buttons do what
they're supposed to do can lizard spit
oh I just through I don't know what that
was all the buttons are crazy so I'm
just you just through bad rancid soup on
hey can you can you say rancid soup and
the scorpion boys yes sir I don't want
to blow your voice so maybe not who's
that guy in the back he's like a waiter
[Music]
yeah so he's like a waiter who's allowed
to observe but not actually wait on
tables Pet Sematary when something comes
back too much yeah yeah all right here
we go last match oh wait this is hockey
yeah I know I thought it was over
yeah the fact you can't here we go
alright if you press up you jump by the
way every go to pro tip it fruits it the
pro face it's so hard to predict you're
good - oh my god I think I've got you on
this one I hate I have a glutton go get
Mortal Kombat X it comes out tonight on
ps4 PC don't be a snap Xbox a game jokes
are for losers gaming download the
mobile game one will read in the new
economy thank you to Ed Boon inside of
me thank you guys for joining us see you
guys next Monday